hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of pax 2014 we're here at
sector G a lot of dirty last appointment
of the day but it's great one mr. will
Miller nice to meet you sir david
McDonough from fair access games hey do
and gentlemen you you literally just ran
over from your panel that finished like
15 minute finishing minutes ago and it
was a packed house I think we were
turning people away at the door wow it
was so awesome to see such enthusiasm
for beyond Earth yes i swatched ater
ain't no small theater as well no it's
not what's it like actually talking to
people obviously praxis this this series
has been going on there for pegada
almost like two decades I'd say at this
stage yeah well what's it like having
feedback having like these passionate
fans actually talking to you and telling
you you made a good game or not well
it's just unbelievable like we we are
for access fans we grew up on their
games and to be on the other side of
that table is like I still don't really
believe it like we were so excited to
make beyond Earth but they have it here
and be able to show it off and see how
people react is unbelievable yeah you
guys are co-lead developers on this and
you would tell me before we started you
guys actually with college together
that's right we've known each other for
almost a decade we went to we went to
college at the Savannah College of Art
and Design and we learned to make games
there together and we learned to program
there together and through luck a lot of
luck I'm hardware a hard work at work we
made it differ access together as leads
on this great game it's just it's the
dream come true excellent so let's talk
about civilization beyond Earth and for
I was equating this wrongfully in the
past to something like opposite sorry
which is a game I have it that dealer
man who had time playing recently and
for folks who haven't played this game
or perhaps aren't very familiar with a
civilization in the sort of the grandest
scale what is beyond Earth well you did
go you spent all right I'm together we
do beyond Earth is the story of
mankind's future if civilization
explores our history in our past beyond
Earth is the story of our future on a
new world and the game the game takes
place about 250 years from now after a
cataclysm we call the great mistake and
the nations of the world have
reorganized themselves and are sending
seed ships out to distant planets and
every time you play a game of beyond our
if you are one of those expeditions so
looking at the game now we've just
landed on a new world where we're
starting to expand there are a lot of
things to do we see the tech web here
the non linear progression is one of the
big new features that we put into the
game so one of our goals with this
product was to make it at the same time
very accessible to civ players hmm and
but at the same time very very different
and to really get you in there and and
to play the long game in a very
different way than you did in citizen
pass it must be inherently different
considering like civilization is almost
you know history is a known quantity
people understand that you know you went
from having foot soldiers to you know
guys on horses two cars two tanks aman
not like how do you show the the
distance in like time and evolution of a
culture when you don't have those
touchstones that people sort of
inherently know about sure well it's
lots of different ways and that's one of
the most fun parts about designing and
playing beyond Earth is it the story
unfolds as the player plays we're really
big on player telling their own story
through through their game plate and
historic sieve is the same way you
effectively get to rewrite history right
you get to say what would happen if
Napoleon and Genghis Khan actually met
well in this game you get to start with
some with some starting conditions that
are pretty close to what we know now you
know not too far away from present-day
yeah but then step by step and like
little choice my little choice grow into
this wild imaginary scientific side
science fiction future and through the
the units that you build the way your
cities look the way you engage in
diplomacy just how you live on this
planet and deal with the life-forms that
already live there all of these add up
to eventually creating the the tale of
what happens to humanity next so I guess
you have a lot of decisions to make when
you land on this planet I guess to sort
of the three main directions alive seed
anyway in the coverage of this game is
the ability to either try and create a
sort of a copy of Earth on this new
planet to maybe try and use genetics to
become more like the species were there
and fit in there is a sort of
technological route
and can you explain just how those
systems work how those choices manifest
for the player what you know are we what
how much control you have over what
direction you want to go in and how much
do your civilization have in terms of
our control well you as you said there's
sort of three ways to approach the
problem of humanity on a new world and
those are harmony purity and supremacy
they're called technology affinities and
as you research technologies in the game
and as you make decisions in the quest
system or discover things on the
planet's surface you begin to devote
your civilization to one of those three
at the end of the game you're inevitably
some mix of the three but you have a
dominant affinity and that has pretty
dramatic implications to how the game
plays yeah so it's you progress your
affinity through technology as one of
the big ones the technological web has
been redesigned so that you start in the
center around things that we more or
less know today and expand outwards
along any direction you want and as you
go and as you sort of express your
priorities like I really care about guns
I really care about energy I really care
about culture your affinity comes
alongside with that you could you
eventually start to take on a flavor
based on what you make and then the
quest system is sort of the other half
that that is sort of a commentary on
what you're already doing as you as you
go through the game quest will come up
that let you try a different tactic or
make a philosophical choice about what
just happened and that is the other half
of you expressing which affinity you
prefer to be so be between the two of
these things an entire game plays or the
story of you coming to terms with who
you're we revolt really going to be and
then expressing it through everything
that you do how difficult is that to
communicate to people who like even i
guess like civilization is a game that's
that's you know relatively difficult to
try and you know get it get into you
lease unique there's a time commitment
involved with and how difficult is it to
try and create a game that has all of
these new systems that not only people
who are completely new to it don't know
but even sip fans presumably this is a
whole new set of rules that's right and
we've we've spent a lot of time trying
to make to strike that balance I think
we have a healthy amount of both respect
for the civilization franchise but also
a reference yeah you know we're both
young designers and this is this is our
first sift title and we come to it with
fresh eyes and
a lot of respect but at the same time or
we're ready to reexamine every system in
the game as it relates to this new
futuristic context and we hope that this
product enjoys a very long life and we
can continue to sort of differentiate it
in really substantial ways but beyond
Earth plays a lot differently from from
coercive if you treat this game like
course if you lose very fast you you
will notice immediately that when you
land on the planet the aliens are sort
of a diplomatic and military entity all
their own that are relevant throughout
the entire game not just the stumbling
block the speed bump that barbarians
Yeah right things like my asthma and the
canyons and everything which are
impediments to you early become
advantages to you later depending on
your affinity devotion and how you
decide to handle those so there are a
lot of these really neat ways that your
civilization changes both mechanically
an aesthetically so your leaders start
to change your city start to change as
you upgrade your military units they
take on different appearance to reflect
all of these choices that you're making
so you get a lot of feedback yeah yeah
and the orbital layer stuff as well as
kind of a new guest layer yeah the
civilization does not before you talk a
little bit about that is that is the end
game stuff for ya yeah IBM the order
layer our gameplay designer anton likes
to describe it as getting to break the
rule of one unit per tile which civ5
introduced yeah and in a sci-fi game is
sort of makes sense that if you can fly
through space and land on a new planet
you could prob ack into space yeah so
right from the very beginning in this
game you get to start adding objects
that are like installations into the
orbital air that let you oughta mentor
change or mess with what's going on down
below and it's an alternative territory
up there that you have to fight for and
control while you were fighting forward
controlling the stuff down below and the
two feedback to each other yeah how do
they interact with each other well the
stuff that you put in orbit affects what
happens on the ground and admit that
could be like economic like it could
make those tiles produce more or could
be military could make it units fight
better the orbital unit itself could
directly attack because a lot of
different things you could do with them
any like Star Wars type laser systems
the not quite like that the simple
but yeah definitely you can you can use
it if you're for conquest if you really
want to or you can use it for you know
diplomacy and making money and
everything else you like to do BUTT
STUFF in orbit can't overlap so if
you're the first one up there you get
the territory you got to hold it but
stuff in orbit also degrades so it
eventually crashed back down opening up
holes in the territory and you have to
go gather up the remains of the crash
satellites to get better Special stone
and then some units on the ground can
actually shoot down orbital units if
they're really causing a problem so
there's a there's a lot of energy
interplay back and forth between the two
and what's the endgame in this situation
when in save it was obvious it was right
you know its history again it's a known
quantity and then you know getting up to
the modern age and launching into space
becomes like the sort of it's it's
always on your mind what's the endgame
is it is it is it taking over the you
know global dominance or is it again
reaching for the stars eventually yeah
you can always win by domination it's a
sieve game so you can kill everybody and
win that you win right but what's cool
about this game is that it starts with
this tremendous event in human history
which is we we we land on a new world
and start colonizing and the game is
bookended at the end by another equally
tremendous event and it's facilitating
one of those events to occur that wins
you the game the three affinity
directions each have their own victory
condition and there's also a victory
condition which is loosely based on carl
sagan's novel contact where you you
discover a mysterious signal build this
giant machine and contact an alien
intelligent alien race for the first
time but we really liked the apollo are
the Alpha Centauri victory from civ
where you have to build these parts it's
kind of an involved process it's not
just reach a threshold with this number
and win yeah right so all of the
victories are couched in these
multistage quests and they all have some
giant thing that you have to construct
and protect they're called a planetary
wonders and you have to give up a tile
in your city to place one of these
things and they're sort of fragile so
you have to protect it but they're all
very sort of involved and narrative lee
driven but
but just systematic as well yeah they're
very cool we it's fun to win this game
and one of the most enjoyable things
about this entire franchise is sort of
letting loose and then you know
restarting a different game and replay
in a different style before how you guys
sort of engaging that like is there much
variety in terms of like outset map
design in terms of like the factions
that are there when you land yeah yeah
that was a huge deal for us like we we
wanted to make this game as customizable
and different every time as we possibly
could and so there's lots of different
ways that you could customize their game
in a different game will be a completely
different experience one of the first is
uh what process we call the seating
which is a very first thing you do in
the game and it's where you actually
assemble the colony ship that's going to
go to the new planet and that's combined
with like the faction that you play the
leader you know the civ but also the
colonists the kind of people you bring
along the kind of spacecraft it is cool
and the kind of cargo you take and all
of that adds up to a customizable
collection of advantages it is who you
are when you land and that governs your
trajectory all the way through the game
and with all the different options every
time you start a new game you could pick
a completely different set you can play
the same leader and have you know dozens
and dozens of different combinations of
ways you could play them and then the AI
leaders that you face they're doing the
same thing so even when you meet the
same leader again in the subsequent game
they may be totally different this time
around I may have brought different
advantages if they have different agenda
you have to figure out again kind of who
they are and what they're about and then
of course the planets themselves like
you're here you're seeing something
we're excited to show off your packs
which is the fungal biome a world this
is new right yeah yeah a world where all
of the vegetation is a form of fungus so
it's really gross and weird it's
probably our most alien looking place
hmm we've already revealed the lush
biome which is very jungly and kind of
earth looking and then the arid biome
which harkens two planets like Arrakis
from doom and so that combined with like
the suite of map options we've got like
four different styles of planets with
different layouts of land and water or
like canyons ice volcanoes all kinds of
craters things like that landing on a
new planet the planet is going to be is
crazy new collection of things on top of
all the things you brought with you on
top of the aliens already there and they
have their own agenda
so every game has got a lot of spin to
make it a different experiment biomes
will it have when it's this is a third
the third of the three that we're gonna
launch with so it's not just the biome
either the biome is sort of the the
aesthetic aspect although there are some
gameplay implications for example in the
arid biome there more worms yeah yeah
because dune right but underneath that
our map scripts which are these these
things that generate you know decide
where all the tiles go where the
resources are and all that and those are
very sophisticated we put a lot of
effort into those and they're also
moddable so we're really excited to see
yeah yeah you guys are diving into that
right well that's an interesting one
like how what how much variety can
happen within that like in terms of the
mod so you expect people to make full
conversions or do you think it'll be
mostly we don't do any guys out we don't
really know I mean we can't really talk
much about it because we don't exactly
know how it's going to play out sure but
just looking at what players did was sit
five hmm I think that we can we were
hoping for a lot of really great fan
enthusiasm for taking what we've done
here and spinning it in their own ways
we've left a lot of systems available to
be like you know attitude or changed or
reworked and I really hope I'm really
excited to see how the mod community
embraces the game I was talking to a
game spots Chris waters that's morning
he said he was Hostgator yeah he was
singing on there i was talking this
morning cuz he's obviously had a lot
more exposure he was telling me about
the m questing system or the quest
system you guys have and he was saying
like for instance there was one where he
went into a cave and there was like a
portal there and you sort of have a
binary decision whether you want to go
into it or not but there's such a
scalability within this quest things is
why you've sort of like long-term goals
as well that's right so there there are
small quests that kind of give you these
binary choices than that that
differentiate and personalize your
civilization and kind of give you a
window as into what's happening on the
ground and then they're more long-term
freeform ones that have a lot of
branching paths that that reinforce
things like affinity late game or in the
early game the quest system is great
because it lets us deliver some of this
sci-fi fiction in context to the player
without compromising their ability to
really tell their own story that the
thing that we like to talk that we like
to say is we we treat our narrative like
the blur
herbs on magic cards okay like magic
cards have this little you know this
little fluff text in there and that's
your window unless you read the novels
that's your window into the world of
magic yeah and that that's a great place
to work from because it doesn't get in
the way of civilizations wonderful
quality of like being this procedural
storytelling engine yeah and it's not
overburdening people with a lot right
off to do as well right and what's it
like for you guys personally working on
this game considering like you know
we're your group relatively new in the
industry I suppose at least for a
franchise of this sort yeah this
magnitude yeah what's it like is it
there's a daunting experience exciting
it's both and it mean it's an honor
really yeah like I said when we started
we both grew up playing the civ games
we're fans of firaxis hmm and to be able
to take on a sieve game a game that will
go into the Canon of civ games it's just
an extraordinary treat really I couldn't
be more grateful to for access for
giving us this opportunity we think
we've made a pretty good game one that
we're proud of but I don't think we'll
ever lose sight of how like special an
opportunity this was and is and how
excited we were to be able to do it and
our team as well i mean i think for
access can put put younger guys in the
driver's seat like john schaefer was
younger than we were we need its 25
because the team that that we're working
with is so so good they've been making
these games since microprose yeah right
a long long time and they really rally
behind this idea and it came together in
really spectacular form but yeah it's
been an honor yeah excellent and we
can't wait to enjoy the fruits of your
labor when will folks be able to
actually get their hands and play for
themselves so Sid Meier's Hills they
should be on earth will be available on
october twenty fourth of this year
worldwide there's no delay for those
people across oceans from the United
States excellence I appreciate it yeah I
thought growing up in Europe very much
appreciate absolutely David Wilson for
access thank you so much for the other
stage I wasn't rushing at your asses
over here as well for your panel not a
problem for you tofu too yeah we do have
food and we can go and you got a nice
place here here at sector G yeah we like
to keep people that fed in water does it
work and your panel as well will be on
gamespot I believe in the next couple of
days as well as some people be able to
check that one out alright that's day
one a penny arcade expo 2014 detective
Jo
it's been real fun Chris waters will be
here on the stage tomorrow i'm about to
go outside and play a bunch of indie
games and may be skulls some delicious
burgers and drinks and whatnot if you
are in seattle by all means come on down
we're just across the road from the expo
hall and if you're not as stay tuned on
gay.com it got way more coverage coming
your way and thanks to everyone in the
production booth everyone who turned up
here as well round of applause for
yourselves folks I will see you guys
tomorrow take care